well it happens every once in a while at
the last minute an interview goes wrong
and I don't mean wrong in the sense that
yesterday's urine injector interview
went wrong I mean like the interview
just doesn't happen because of a problem
so we're going to take a few calls let's
hear from a few people in the audience
rare that we're able to do this on a
Wednesday but let's see what we get okay
why don't we start first with Jay from
Ontario Jay from Ontario welcome to the
program
hello yes you're on the air
uh I was just curious with the whole um
the news about uh Trump and uh whatever
the other guy's name is uh Giuliani
rather selling pardons for two million I
wonder if it's the in the best interest
of Democrats to try to pass a bunch of
laws
um not allowing presidents to have so
much power and I know that that could be
a wide range of things but I wanted to
know your thoughts on that if the
Democrats should try to do that well I
mean sure that the problem is that
presidential pardon power is not a
likely thing to be changed and so then
the question becomes what exactly are
you trying to take away as far as Powers
go now here's here's what I will say jay
one of the realities that the Trump
presidency exposed
is that our safeguards and checks and
balances aren't as robust and
impenetrable as maybe the framers of the
Constitution believe them to be and in
the defense of the framers they probably
reasonably never believed someone as
willing to flout all of those checks and
balances As Trump would come to power
now you could say well they should have
foreseen that okay but they didn't so
then the question becomes what exactly
is it that you would want to change I
don't know if you have something in mind
no I don't and I think that's the big
problem is that yeah the Trump
presidency exposed that there's probably
a lot of things that we do need to worry
about that we never thought that we
would have to absolutely and when it
comes to Pardon you know the crazy thing
as we talked about earlier in the week
it's not explicit it appears not to be
explicitly illegal for the president to
sell pardons except if it counts as a
bribe or as a fraudulent or obstructive
act and you know to be totally honest I
don't think this selling pardons for 2
million thing is going to go very far I
hope to be wrong and I hope to eat my
hat on it even though I don't wear hats
but I actually don't think it's going to
go very far
yeah I I guess I agree
are you calling from Ontario Canada yes
beautiful how is it there
uh no complaints weather's pretty good I
guess that's good all right Jay thank
you for the call yeah thanks for having
me on David take care all right there
goes Jay from Ontario calling in very
strongly let's go to Liam from Austin
Texas Liam are you thrilled to have Elon
Musk in Austin these days or what
I'm sorry David could you repeat that
question please no I was joking whether
you were glad that Elon Musk is in your
neck of the woods
oh uh yeah not particularly you know I'm
coming to Austin yeah I'm in Austin for
college so it's really weird you know
um campus is not the same as the city
where it feels a lot more like San
Francisco right
well what's on your mind today
David uh this is more of a broad
question but it's addressed towards you
specifically so
of many of the political pundits that I
follow
you come across to me as one of the most
eloquent well-spoken articulated and I
just I wanted to ask you I know I think
you majored in Communications if I did
my research right I just want to know
like how did you get to that point
because you know I really want to be a
good public speaker but I feel like I'm
just not you know so a couple different
things first of all uh we you could have
even included a little more praise
really Liam I don't like that you cut it
off so early we could have done with
more of it no I'm kidding no so here's
the thing there's a lot of different
things I I do think that there is some
predisposition to people who are more or
less comfortable talking and I I just
think it's an open question
to the degree to which one can kind of
like learn to be comfortable talking but
I think it's a bunch of different things
first of all I learned English as a
second language I I it's it's a native
language in the sense that I started
learning it when I was five but I do
think that the process of translating
what you know in one language to a new
language probably helps language
development to some degree
I read a ton since I was a kid
and I think reading is probably the best
way to build vocabulary and to
experience different sorts of sentence
structure and this sort of thing I think
that working in sales was hugely helpful
I've told my Circuit City War Stories
you know being 16 and being put in a
position of selling three thousand
dollar laptops to uh you know 45 year
olds bringing their kid to college or
whatever it kind of forces you to either
sink or swim and develop a rapport and
comfort thinking on your feet and that
sort of thing and then I think just by
like doing a show so I don't know that
there's really an answer in there but I
think all of those things you know I've
attended I've been invited to attend
sometimes like Toastmasters as a public
speaking group where people take turns
speaking and stuff like that I I don't
know to what degree stuff like that is
useful but maybe it is but those are a
few things that come to mind
yeah that's very helpful now do you
think this is a quick follow-up do you
think that you were kind of always since
you were you can remember naturally
predisposed towards speaking publicly
you're very comfortable with yourself
like that because I've always felt kind
of like an anxious person no I mean to
be honest when I do in-person stuff it's
like you know we get one and a half
million views a day on YouTube and 30 40
000 podcast downloads a day
and it's just second nature at this
point because I'm so used to it however
if I'm speaking to a room in person of
50 people I still get sort of nervous so
I don't I don't think that goes away and
I've spoken to people who speak to
really large groups in person they all
have said to me if you don't get a
little anxious before that then then
something actually might be wrong that's
actually a good thing that's a normal
thing obviously if it becomes disabling
it's a problem
right well David sir I greatly have
tears in my eyes I just so much
appreciate your time today well Liam I'm
sorry I made you cry but I do appreciate
the call
all right thank you there is Liam from
Austin let's go next to Jane from
Hollywood Jane from Hollywood welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
hi
hi times I'm an organizer in Orange
County California this is where the GOP
comes to fundraise right okay yes one of
the hottest uh political spot we have
four congressional districts that are
always up for grabs and they go both
ways
um I've tried to contact you a few times
um but like your technology is kind of
complicated I'll be real with you tell
me what you mean by that Jane what's
complicated about it
the waiting room is silent and so I just
got into a different room in Discord
look I'm a little bit older okay okay
I'm 49. I don't get all this stuff and
it's a little bit complicated well James
since you've been trying to get a hold
of me for so long and we are you now did
let's waste no more time and get right
into your question
okay well my name's not Hollywood Jane
my name's Jenna okay that's my screen
name and well I only see what you type
in so that's why I called you that
I got you I got you I was a team lead
for Unite Here Local 11. okay okay I
would I was walking in the field I
helped get utos
Martinez elected in LA
I worked on several campaigns
currently they are I I don't know how it
went because I couldn't find the link
yesterday because there was supposed to
be a vote in Anaheim yesterday on a
measure they were walking in Anaheim
to raise the minimum wage for the hotel
and concierge staff in Anaheim
to be 25 an hour right
the people that they walked that watched
that measure that had the persuasive
conversations
were paid twenty dollars an hour
and they were considered temporary
employees and they did not have written
job descriptions they did not have
safety protocols and while I was a team
lead on that campaign I was bit by an
attack dog and I'm now permanently
disabled
and so when we talked about like how are
Democrats going to win 2024 they're not
going to do it through hypocrisy you
know what I'm saying
um
I will never walk the same again
and I was training up these kids to go
into these doors knock on them and have
the conversations necessary to convince
people to
um put measures on the ballot that would
help workers you know what I'm saying
and so when we talk about like how do we
advance
um Democrats in a a situation where
there's fascism against us we can't be
Hypocrites about it we can't constantly
be like we're gonna use temporary
employment loopholes to take exploit
other workers to advance the rights of
the workers who are paying our union
dues
well I agree with you completely it's an
important point and one that's well said
the organizing can't be as problematic
as the labor situation that the
organizers are trying to fix I do I know
nothing about the specifics you've cited
Hollywood Jane but I will look into it
and I really appreciate you calling in
and letting me know about that we will
investigate and we will follow up